if worse comes to worse we'll just go to
that no the new plan is they discover
a Trappist exoplanets I meant to talk
about this like two weeks ago when it
was a big thing now you're forgotten
about it what is it we had two guests
you know two weeks back-to-back so we
couldn't talk about exoplanets but I
really want to explain to us what those
are these don't know dude 48 about 42
light-years away from here which is
basically like not visible at all
there's this it's 315 no listen how far
it is this [ __ ] [ __ ]
315 trillion miles away Oh
41 light-years and you know between like
its million trillion you know I mean
miles oh we ain't going yeah but if you
if we were going if Kang and I were
going yeah what would I mean settlement
if we could go let's say someone Elon
Musk was like holy [ __ ] here's a little
space capsule we're taking two podcaster
yes and you're like you know we promised
you that the air is breathable the
atmosphere is livable and we just don't
know the types of animals that actually
live there would we go it was if they
didn't okay we don't know could we come
back though yes but there's always
there's always no no we can't go back no
no let's get about this you and I
one-way ticket but we know we're gonna
live because there's oxygen right do we
know that it's oxygen I don't want
implode that was a [ __ ] stupid so you
and I go but we don't know anything else
we don't know if there's water hold on
first question we could take a third
person do we take Gilbert or George
definitely Gilbert I'm the smart you're
not a part of my plans bro yeah he's
gonna tie our survival man because if
she dies he though I'm [ __ ] him yeah
okay whatever I can get pregnant from
the but yeah only in the exoplanet you
know it's gay sex actually leaves the
reproduction yes true but if I show up
on this on this planet and we know
there's oxygen there's probably water if
there's oxygen right
some people don't know like oh no all
right
and there are Hills are there Hill why
after water Hills I love to roll down
hills I don't want it to be just water
flat tectonic plates gonna be water yeah
yeah good so I need water
I need feel they're gonna be heels if
they're plate movement pastures will
there be pastures just already just
pastures okay good you don't know what
kind of animal right but then we'll help
what I'll do is I'll go we'll go down to
UM Walmart
there's a Walmart in this earth what are
you getting for you go to like Arkansas
we'll go to Walmart or get shot guns and
guns and stuff right three things on me
you can throw that in there is capsule
we can only bring like a sack of
potatoes and like a few other see grow
grow I would definitely bring the three
things that you don't need then the
smart only see okay oh you you know the
first thing obviously seeds Bobby your
first thing one flipper obviously for
the puddles yeah yeah klava second thing
a very well sharpened machete smart okay
Bobby's a monocle good vibrant bottom
hiking shoes sure
beat it nerd the [ __ ] is that Bobby your
third thing a jar with a moth in it
we copulate yeah you are you ready Bobby
leave no article no sir yeah yeah yeah I
would bring the three wrong things I
already know but that's [ __ ] we
shouldn't you shouldn't put a cap on how
many things see whatever you want right
I think we should bring be able to have
shotguns and guns so that we can survive
right seeds so we can plant [ __ ] right
and like some sort of like machetes and
and things that we can build things with
because if there's water we can assume
that there's wood right so we'll maybe
we do need you yeah we'll have you chop
assumptions chop some [ __ ] we might have
to Skype you what would you do
you know how long that would take that
transmission see again weird aliens of
your hand were dead yeah but um so yeah
and but then we don't know what kind of
animals it's a woman what type of
animals do you but if there was just all
naked women oh my god oh my god I can
tell unless no what I wouldn't cheat on
me yeah I would Wow that's why you can
scissor them all just [ __ ] jerk off
[Music]
next one go yeah my flippers my favorite
lesbian you're my favorite lesbian where
this is gonna release someone's gonna
cut that out put her in a montage is
that dropping the toys in a drop of my
LGBTQ comment but that would be exciting
though I also did these Erb these
planets don't rotate so only one side of
these planets get the Sun so the other
side is completely dark yeah the whole
rotate on an axis yeah so you could but
you'd have to probably live right at
where you could cross over between light
and dark so you would have to land very
very specific yeah yeah actually it's
but it's pretty gradual so you'd have to
walk like [ __ ] that's a good movie
idea what you know a colony could they
go to a you know a planet that doesn't
rotate it's the only Sun on one side but
they don't can't tell what's on the
other side and they cross the thing and
it gets crazy so what lives and the dark
doesn't live in the lie yeah maybe it's
like space vampires oh and they land on
the wrong side of the planet weather now
the whole movie they're trying to get to
the other side of the planet where the
light is
write that down dude right it's like
space aliens right did you know this the
colony ship whatever goes haywire yeah
they crash under the dark part not
knowing right yeah stay dark right and
then they realize that it's like some
sort of like alien but they don't throw
like vampires and it's the whole movie
they're just trying to get you know and
then they get to the light part and
something worse happens
there's Mexicans a planet yeah we skip
the vampires there's like older leg
right yeah what a good what a good M
night Shyamalan yeah Mexican stand which
pitchforks a cell phone
[Music]